y
[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente desde casa
en france 24 si ha estado en europa o en
algunas ciudades del sur de eeuu quizás
se haya dado cuenta de la existencia de
cientos o miles de periquitos monje que
justo al atardecer muestran su lado más
conversador estos pájaros de un verde
llamativo pueden resultar agradables y
exóticos a la vista sin embargo al no
ser especies autóctonas suponen una
posible amenaza para otros tipos de
pájaros al competir en espacio para
hacer nidos o en la disponibilidad de
alimento esa es la preocupación de la
comunidad científica en italia uno de
los países europeos en los que estos
pajaritos se están acostumbrando a vivir
y donde se están reproduciendo
desmesuradamente esto a pesar de estar
muy lejos de su lugar de origen el
continente latinoamericano nuestra
corresponsal en roma' natalia mendoza
habló con científicos de aliados al
respecto
últimamente en las calles de la ciudad
eterna se nota una presencia insólita
pequeños loros verdes originarios del
continente latinoamericano que han
invadido la fauna local y son cada vez
más visibles algo que aprecian los
habitantes de roma
son bellos y ahora se ven por todos
lados nos hacen compañía y son muy
agradables de mirar ave la col
me gustan los colores de sus plumas
antes sólo se veían en los documentales
pero ahora los tenemos aquí enfrente
hasta corrado battisti es ornitólogo en
los últimos años ha estudiado el aumento
exponencial de esos loros tropicales en
italia y el impacto que han tenido en el
medio ambiente local fin en 1990 94 los
primeros especímenes llegaron a italia
en los años noventas se reprodujeron y
cada año han ido doblando su población
el problema es que desequilibra en el
hábitat porque ocupan el espacio que
utilizan las especies autóctonas para
hacer sus nidos
unidos en las cavidades de los troncos o
en medio de las ramas de esta comida en
asia están construyendo un nido lo están
preparando para la próxima primavera
primavera cómplice de esta situación
el clima cada vez más cálido en la
península italiana en consecuencia del
calentamiento global algo que ha
favorecido la adaptación de varias de
estas especies que han sido catalogadas
por las autoridades medioambientales del
país
este es el periquito monje originario de
américa del sur la zona del brasil este
y este de aquí es un papagayo amazónico
ahora se ven en casi todas las regiones
italianas
hablamos de decenas de miles de
ejemplares individuo por el momento
estas curiosas aves se concentran en las
zonas urbanas pero se teme que en los
próximos años nygren al campo en donde
podrían ser una amenaza para la
agricultura italiana
y es que el temor de los científicos
italianos no es infundado la
introducción de especies invasoras a un
ecosistema es uno de los motores
directos de la pérdida de biodiversidad
a nivel global
de hecho el controlar y el evitar la
entrada de especies foráneas está
contemplado como el noveno objetivo de
las metas haití acordadas en 2010 en el
marco de la convención de diversidad
biológica en cuanto a este objetivo se
ha avanzado mucho en los últimos 10 años
en la identificación de especies
invasoras y en su clasificación de
acuerdo al riesgo que suponen sin
embargo como vemos en la gráfica no se
ha avanzado casi en lograr la
erradicación de estas que sólo se ha
conseguido en algunas islas tampoco se
ha podido ralentizar la introducción de
especies invasoras de hecho de las 20
metas haití para la diversidad biológica
que se habían planteado para que se
fueran cumplidas en su totalidad antes
del año 2020 sólo algunas se han
completado y sólo de manera parcial ya
ha iniciado el 2021 el reto de las
especies invasoras continúa desde la
patagonia chilena en donde los castores
están amenazando sus bosques nativos
y su fauna hasta eeuu o francia con el
avispón asiático gigante o incluso
varios países africanos como sudáfrica o
camerún donde especies vegetales
llegadas de brasil y del norte de
argentina están invadiendo lagos y
obstruyendo la salida a la superficie de
los manatíes africanos para poder
respirar las especies invasoras afectan
a todo el planeta y no sólo en cuanto a
la reducción de la biodiversidad sino
que además causan grandes pérdidas
económicas la introducción de especies
poder ser natural o humana por accidente
o voluntaria así sucedió en chile donde
en 1946 militares argentinos trajeron
desde norteamérica a 10 parejas de
castores a tierra de fuego queriendo
comercializar la piel del animal pero el
negocio no tuvo éxito y estos animales
quedaron libres y se fueron
reproduciendo y expandiendo por la
región hasta llegar a una población
estimada actual de más de 100 mil
ejemplares
el bosque no tiene cómo defenderse el
cachorro de la corteza porque es la
parte viva en la parte rica del árbol de
la cual se alimenta el castor y mata a
los árboles nos mata en pie al construir
su represa sus lagunas inunda valles
inunda bosques y mata todo lo que está
alrededor en el medio del agua se mueve
porque nuestros bosques no están
preparado para dicho uso del agua en
chile están tratando de erradicar a la
población de castores con trampas o
cazando los con rifles en otras partes
del mundo luchan contra las especies
invasoras comiéndose las como por
ejemplo en el sur de eeuu donde puedes
encontrar platos como pesto de curuzú
una planta trepadora proveniente de
japón o también pez león frito una
especie originaria del índico que causa
graves daños en los arrecifes de coral
del golfo de méxico y del caribe
latinoamericano en sudáfrica la pesca de
la carpa tiene un doble objetivo por un
lado controlar a este pez invasor
introducido en el país en el siglo 19 y
por otro ayudar a familias que durante
la pandemia han tenido problemas para
conseguir alimento
como ven hay muchas maneras de
contribuir a la solución pero lo más
importante es evitar ser transportador
de especies invasoras y lo podemos
evitar asegurándonos de que lo que
planteamos en nuestros jardines o casas
sean especies nativas también cuando
vayamos al campo no botar semillas de
frutas que no pertenezcan al lugar o si
vamos de camping y hacemos una fogata
intentar siempre utilizar tipos de
maderas locales así me despido por estas
semanas sigan con más medio ambiente en
france24 punto com
[Música]